[Music]
[Music]
like the rising and setting of this
[Music]
excuse me we're born into darkness and
rise up to the greatest peaks before
descending into darkness once more a
warrior and the sophist this is a first
it is not philosophy its truth learn
through violence feint in seeing evil
true evil you're talking about the
riving threat the creature when it
ambushed us outside we thought only of
survival my spear allowed me to stay out
of its gaze I was lucky my friends
weren't tell me how you were able to
defeat the creature it all happened so
fast
we had a plan to break into the temple
and corner it but it ambushed us before
we got inside there was no time for
strategy after that
why go after the creature in the first
place we were hired to steal an ancient
item from within its lair by masked
soldiers tell me about the item they
wanted you to steal truth is I don't
even think they knew exactly what it is
after I killed the creature I went to
search the lair but it was sealed
give me that spear we are warriors to
let it go without a fight will be to
dishonor my fallen friend
[Music]
[Music]
nothing special about this year
[Music]
the mercenary knew nothing he never made
it inside the lair then it was a waste
of time he awaits and we've done nothing
to help her
not exactly the mercenary carried this
spear which she claims killed the riding
thread no no the creature took it a year
it can't be dead it waits in its lair
even now then there may be a piece of
this puzzle we don't yet understand have
you found the way inside the lair
Lydia's story was true the daughters of
Artemis were protecting this disk key
this I have what opens the lair and you
didn't hurt any of the daughters when
you took it
they didn't hear me or my blades but
they felt them please why why would you
this disk is a prized possession if I
hadn't killed them I never would have
made it out alive and lugia would be
lost I suppose you did what you had to
Lydia's worth any price
[Music]
please wait
please you have no idea what you're
please
only one yeah
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
vices I hate snakes
someone I tell you in another time will
remember us